representatives from EU Member States
taking part in the banking union have
signed an agreement on transferring
finances and sharing them in a common
fund to help out ailing banks the funds
part of the so called single resolution
mechanism which consists of a board of
members who decide how to wind down or
restructure banks that are no longer
viable
once regular financing options have been
exhausted the board could draw on the
single resolution fund which will
eventually total some 55 billion euros
this would help limit costs to average
European citizens and the real economy
no longer do the taxpayers bail out
failing banks but investors are bailed
in and that will change the rules of the
game significantly the European Central
Bank will act as a supervisor and early
warning system alerting the board if a
banks in trouble or likely to fail apart
from helping to ward off any looming
crisis
the mechanism is expected to boost
economic growth as confidence grows that
Europe's banks are all using the same
rulebook
it would also sidestep the risks of
contagion and avoid the problems
involved in having national authorities
wind down cross-border banks it's it's a
very easy system and you can compare it
actually to how you organize your
financial market domestically you have
one supervisor you have one set of rules
which stabilizes expectations of
investors of consumers of depositors in
practice it requires a large set of
rules which sometimes are mathematical
and sometimes organizational but the
principle itself as we show here is an
easy one the single resolution mechanism
will start going into operation on
January 1st it will apply to banks in
the eurozone and other EU member states
that choose to join the banking Union